a French astronaut satellite providing a
navigation system the rm6 launch rocket
what do they all have in common these
space programs aspire to achieve
European excellence that's all part of
what may be called space 40 1.0 is
astronomy 2.0 is the race in space 3.0
is more or less what we have today we
have some cooperation international
cooperation but space 4.0 is really the
real stuff meaning its commercialization
its participation it is using space for
all the different possibilities for jobs
and crows the European Parliament
scientific body quiz various actors of
the space industry the conclusion is
clear there is a strong need for
cooperation between public and private
actors investing into the future space
activity requires a lot of money private
sector giants like SpaceX and others are
going to be driving the space agenda
increasingly and so is going to be quite
a interesting growth over the next
decade or so how the institutional side
of space and the commercial side of
space work together space can seem
remote for some to mep s can have a role
in showing that you space programs
deliver services that benefit millions
of people from air transport to mobile
phones border control and even
agriculture we have done work on the
satellites with Galileo and Copernicus
they're looking down at the earth we
also need to look out at space but just
providing that floor that ensures we can
reach out to the stars